[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
a couple years ago my brother and i were
diagnosed with a neurodegenerative
illness that has already severely
skipped okay i'm kidding
let me tell you something i haven't been
in a room this small with this many
people
in high school since i was in high
school yeah there's so many [ __ ]
people
that in the cameras don't see i know you
could probably do weird [ __ ] on the road
dude what do you think like you probably
like i heard that you don't hang out
with your [ __ ] openers right no what
the [ __ ] we sleeps all day i sleep all
day but okay you don't hang out with
them at night though no yeah that's
[ __ ] weird why why bring them then
i'll tell you why
you no i'll tell you why i bring them
you always tell you why i bring them
scream dude i know because you dream
scream scream all the [ __ ] time no
matter where you are you scream because
i'm right here this room is [ __ ]
small as [ __ ] i'll tell you what and
we're miked i'll tell you what all right
i can hear you just as well i'll tell
you why why
because um why do you have a vacuum
it's our status oh wow
wow yeah there's a they have a [ __ ]
vacuum as a camera as a tripod i'm sorry
um some some of the tripods i'm sorry
some podcasts are doing as well as some
other ones you don't you know what the
money you do very well don't make enough
money to have a regular like
17 ways
yeah
you know so you know sometimes i feel
like
one of these times is going to be here
and they're going to be like oh in the
middle of the pocket like oh we just had
another one and then the baby's just
going to be here
18 ways yeah
cnn had this like video of like parents
watched looking at their like teenage
kids that died in this very
and then you could hear them through the
tent crying
and i watched that video like a hundred
times so i could cry too but why because
i don't even want to hear you talk about
it no because i want to cry i know you
feel dead inside that you feel like you
need to pull from these things to feel i
feel like i am you know i'll be honest
with you i think i am dead inside no
what you you know why you're dead inside
why because you [ __ ] eat at a diner
finish and then rush out
you don't think that you're jaded of
things like yeah i do but but i'm
talking about like jaded in a
conversation like you know we do stand
up and we do what we do and we're
[ __ ] failing and people are booing at
us and [ __ ] yeah and we you know
sometimes we're [ __ ] doing great
whatever but like
that means that when i'm at a party i
don't want to talk to somebody about
their [ __ ] kid
yeah but that's all that means yeah
but because like oh i i go up on stage
and i [ __ ] have 400 people to 2 000
people a night
waiting on me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and
you want to have a conversation
yeah
i like that song do you really do yeah
yeah yeah i wanna [ __ ] i wanna i
wanna hate but i like that song man so
much and i like you can i never and
there's too many [ __ ] people in this
room
and there's still too many people in
this room you literally have a guy in
the closet and that's [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah yeah were you here last time
yeah
you were you're here last time jason
it's always a different it's always a
different guy yeah yeah yeah you just
pick up random dudes no we just have to
some people are busy there's like an
american indian therefore
he
are you sleeping
all right anyway oh man i think this is
a good time baby get it out get it off
our chest why not
go ahead okay what is it i do
you're oh first of all you you don't
first of all there's a few things you
don't text back
that's not okay dude
look at him everyone here is nodding
i need a pen and i know you don't do it
i don't know
i need to write down no i got right here
i got a pen right here and i know what
text wait text back right text back
okay go ahead
what are you going to do with this by
the way when we're done i need to i have
a rebuttals
oh okay yeah i'm gonna get the list
okay you don't text back okay um when we
go to a diner yeah you just eat and then
you're done and you leave and i don't
like that
it's for hanging out and you go to a
diner to eat and that's not cool you go
to a dinner to hang out with your
friends number one okay
number uh number number three is um
oh [ __ ] what was the other one i just i
know exactly what what what
is that when i see you in public i get
the comedy stores i don't get into
conversation yeah no yeah um it's fine
that we don't get into a conversation
but you just you just you don't
sometimes you just walk by yeah and you
and you say hey to like some other
people like kevin christie or whoever
which you're friends with and i love
kevin yeah but then you won't say hi to
me okay good um don't say hi
don't stay high and i can't wait yeah
what are you thinking of in a second
yeah yeah you have some rebuttals okay
oh you're [ __ ] okay
when we're at a diner sometimes you'll
you'll be like uh and you'll start
playing your games
and and and
that's not for that that's not for that
that's not someone is speaking on my
behalf yeah games
okay is that everything that's good
those are good that's a very good thing
very good chris yeah very good [ __ ]
rebuttal i love you oh that's very very
good i love you it's the disrespect we
were talking about because you don't
even know what's going on with my body
right now you know what i i i guarantee
i don't no you don't i'm gonna tell you
what's going on okay right i have fungi
on my dick okay hey man
uh is that real yeah okay why are you
telling me now
and also why are you saying it on your
podcast because it's real okay it does
a lot of things are real right yeah and
we don't say oh it's itchy okay so what
the [ __ ] since you brought it up is
going on yeah and you've already talked
about on the podcast i was playing no
not really first time i was playing not
really really yeah i was playing ping
pong
okay you know what you get a fun guy on
your dick yeah
[Laughter]
i was playing ping pong okay and um i
wasn't wearing uh underwear because um
i just wasn't because you're bobby lee
yeah yeah and i had raw denim that i
don't wash oh you're bobby lee yeah yeah
yeah and i was like you know i
i straight you know when i'm playing
ping pong i stretch yeah and my raw
denim scraped against between my sack
and my thigh and it made a scar yep okay
so it got in shaved and it got a little
infection yep and then i put
antibiotic cream on it and it turned
into fungi absolutely gross
and let me tell you something yeah one
time i was in love
yeah i was in las vegas and i had my
buddy with me this is [ __ ] so long
ago and he was like damn i didn't bring
enough underwear and he [ __ ] wore his
jeans
and we were walking around the casino
and he was like
she was like god damn it man
he's like i wish i had [ __ ] underwear
dude the way these jeans are
the way these jeans are rub against the
tip of my dick to it
it wasn't bad at first but i take so
many steps around the casino that it
just [ __ ] hurts
but he wanted to get laid and he was
like now i can't even get laid my dick
is bright red
oh [ __ ] i just remember that we were
laughing so [ __ ] hard all right text
back number one okay
communication with your phone right for
me is a lifeline to the world
just listen to what i'm saying i know
you're doing your eyes and they're baggy
right now
all that [ __ ] that you do right
so i'm 45. i'll be honest with you and
i'm in the car i get a text from chris
brah brah right
i i spend minutes going how do i respond
to this
why did you say private no i so i just
kind of let it go
okay yeah so
if you were to do something like hey
dude i went to the hospital and i got
some bad news right let me tell you
something right now
no no no fake crying okay go ahead sorry
let me tell you something right now
right i'd be the first one to text you
back i know dude but let me ask you a
question yeah
why
why why why would you be the first one
because i love you so much i think
what it is yeah you secretly want to get
in good with god
um but i think that's sitting around
doing nothing
is not
good you know there was a
i'll get i'm going to tell you a movie
it's a movie called ikeru
it's a
it's a kurosawa film
and it's about a
it was i think the movie would
i decided that i thought i know i know
but can i just do this
you know what you two laughing like that
right and you too
that's that you're going to get i'm
going to get you back for that okay
there's revenge
from my part because that was that was
you not being on my side
and that was very funny by the way that
was good
but
the second one is this i eat and i'm
done okay let me tell you something
right now friend all right all right bro
you're i don't you're pointing at me
let me tell you something about you
right now right okay all right let me
say something all right to survive in
life you need several things you need
oxygen yeah right you need h2o what is
that water water right you need sleep
shelter right and [ __ ] food right
right right right so what i'm saying to
you right now is is that like if you and
i were like camping we're sleeping yeah
and when i'm done sleeping yeah i'm not
gonna just lay next to you
right in the tent and just watch you
[ __ ] sleep right i'm gonna go out
chop some wood for us so we'll get some
fire
right i'm gonna get the bow and arrows
ready so yeah
yeah
i'm gonna get bow and arrows ready for
us for the great hunt
right yeah sure right and then like an
hour later you wake up and i already
have coffee ready for you dude yeah but
you guys what i'm saying is that's what
eating to me is eating is once i'm done
eating i'm off he doesn't know how to
just hang out i know that's a big that's
the bigger thing there last week we went
to shabu-shabu and you sit on those
large um it's almost like a
communal kind of area
and
it's just him and i right halfway
through the meal i'm not done yet he's
out smoking a cigarette and then he pays
and i'm still eating there for the last
20 minutes by myself okay it's just not
you it's everybody yeah i don't know why
i know it's not just me but so what so
then what do you do when he's out there
in the beginning it used to really
perturb me i would imagine it used to
make oh my god it used to really bother
me and at some point i realized it was
probably just his add taking over it is
yeah
it wasn't anything i could take
personally
i need help
okay yeah yeah all right okay next third
so i did that yeah i won the textbook
dude bobby one chris zero one zero bobby
you want to eat i'm
can i ask you a question i'm sir chris
deleo all right why do you have bags
under your eyes do you not sleep good
last night i know no you know what it's
the [ __ ] lighting probably but also i
got bags under my eyes but they're
[ __ ] prada dude
it is proud of gucci yeah man i got
gucci got pride yeah yeah yeah i got
bags but it's all good i'm drizzled man
i got the [ __ ] [ __ ] coming out i got
salt and pepper coming in yeah i mean
i'm 38 dude what do you want from me i
know you're [ __ ] tall i'm a tall
drink of water and i got bags underneath
he's fine yeah but can i say something
what's up you're handsome thank you
that's a good thing yeah thank you
you're artistic okay very creative thank
you right and you are who you are thank
you and that's a compliment those are
three really good compliments those are
very good compliments and can i say this
right now okay um drop the attitude you
know what dude yeah yeah
i i'm being real right now yeah i know
you are i know could i just see this i
want to say this all right okay i love
you thank you no no let me see what okay
dude you know what you're like [ __ ]
stalling bro
people can just talk i know people could
just say but i you know when i say when
i want to be real go ahead how many
times he's already told me not to talk
twice i'm a [ __ ] guest on he's got
their podcast i know but why is he
telling me and then you can say don't
say hi i got a great thing for okay this
is it all right
so you know usually you and i will see
each other primarily in a social setting
like a comedy club right okay
so here's a guy right he's a uh a
good-looking male
you know alpha male stand-up who's
successful
did two shows back to back on a network
right he's you know he's like um you
know he's the light and there's mobs
around him
oh just hear me out okay all right
so i i pull up right i got nothing my my
light is dim that's stupid i know i'm
going to give you an analogy oh yeah let
me talk all right
everybody wants to walk it like one
month go is that a lie or whatever
is that a lie yeah but then i see a
brighter light right
then i go
i ain't no [ __ ] moth bro right
i'm a light too right hmm do you hear
what i'm saying
so it's like when a dimmer light goes
into a brighter light when he has all
those moths sometimes the dimmer light
will just walk on by
yeah and doesn't say hello all right
because they're lights yeah what because
they're lights
no he's just saying yeah you're not
listening
you shut the [ __ ] up right now
i mean i love you but shut the [ __ ] up
that's why i understand but
the [ __ ] but you're
was that
but you're you're you're bigger than
that you know what i mean
no
yeah you are because you'll say hi
you'll say hi to other people right and
then you won't say hi to me maybe he'll
say hi to the matching lights people who
are in the same
baby
i couldn't have said it better yeah but
that's the thing though yeah
that's the [ __ ] 25 disrespect is what
i'm talking about you think i need that
you think i need someone you think he
needs to walk by yeah i don't need that
[ __ ]
well you need more moths no
no you you are who you are in your head
bro not on the outside man
i am who i am in my head do it when you
walk by you don't say [ __ ]
yeah i'm inside my head bro yeah
how do you think i get facebook guys
hey right now right now that one a draw
you know what it's a draw it's only two
zero
it's only two zero okay
that's a draw that was a good point all
right he won that all right that's
actually two
you maybe won the camping analogy one
but not the texting one dude
all right i think it's high it's two two
one one let's just keep it one one okay
one all right
games
wait wait wait wait so it's really his
stepson but he tells us but he tells
people that he it's his real biological
yeah and so it's it's a it's a white lie
that doesn't really hurt anybody yeah
give me another email no he wants to be
remain friends with his he feels like
he's lying to people but he doesn't want
to be lying to them after he gets out i
lie every day right
serious lies right
well that's a serious lie all right so
it's like and i free i have wings
true right and you are wearing that's a
white line you are wearing an army shirt
exactly and i was in the navy
seal really that was in the navy you
were in the navy sea yeah yeah yeah well
maybe that's one of those lies yeah
that's another lie i don't feel bad
about it there you go yeah
yeah i mean great great unhealthy i'm a
quarter mongoose real an animal yeah
yeah wow and you just throw it out there
right and see if it sticks some people
will believe it yeah
that's a real word that is changing such
a challenge give me another email so
he's good he shouldn't say yeah yeah
don't say nothing i think he should but
i don't think his friends would think it
was anything serious either yeah dude
eat it
no just be like yo i was i was [ __ ] i
don't know why i said that it was it
started as a joke and i just was [ __ ]
around and the kids not mine but dude
and then if somebody goes like this oh
that's not cool be like yo i'll nuttin
your girl and have a kid that way if you
don't
yeah let's take it to the real daddy
i'll be the real daddy then how about
that but is it is does this nut not work
bro
it's just he's not part of the email
part of the email i know but that has
nothing to do with it well what kind of
shirt is he wearing right now it doesn't
oh that doesn't matter either yeah no
but i want to know if his nut works
you're going to have to taste it there's
one
and if i taste it and it squirms in my
mouth like if i see little particles
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]